VAN RIPER: Welcome,
everyone in the room here,
and those of you that are
watching on Livestream,
or watching the recording
later, also welcome.
I'm Van Riper.
I run the gPause
program here at Google,
which is-- mission is to support
communities of mindful living
at every Google office.
Yes, it's a fun job.
Today we have Lane Michel here.
And he's going to introduce
the research tools and concrete
practices that increase
well-being, mental clarity,
performance, and
emotional stability
when our heart and mind
work better together.
As a coach and
consultant, he has
helped many people and
companies reach deep
into their truth to make
positive, sustained changes.
Lane is the founder
of VeraHeart,
living his heart adventure
as an engineer, executive,
entrepreneur, inspirational
guide, writer,
and HeartMath certified trainer.
Please join me in
welcoming Lane Michel.
LANE MICHEL: Thank you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Really an honor to
be with you guys,
and be connected in helping out
with the gPause group as well,
which is pretty phenomenal.
When I started VeraHeart
a couple of years ago,
it was really with the
idea that this was the time
to advance mindfulness and
what I was calling heartfulness
in business, but in our
personal lives as well.
And that led to
building or searching
for best materials
for empowerment
for supporting choice
and for supporting
being more in our own energy.
And extending that
to organizations,
so that organizations
could become energized.
And VeraHeart's tagline is about
developing energized people
and companies.
And this whole idea of opening
up the energy that we have,
unleashing new potential, is a
very exciting time right now.
The part I want to share
with you in this segment
is about human
energy, our system,
and how some biofeedback
tools, the research and science
behind those, is
helping to improve
how we can access
more of our energy,
build more of our energy.
And frankly, achieve
more as well,
both personally and as
organizations come together
using these practices as a team.
So that's where we're going to
focus on those elements today.
First of all, so hashtags.
I go out and search for anything
to do with energy and people.
And what do you
imagine that I find?
It's oil, petroleum, it's solar.
The idea of we as a
human energy system
is just about nonexistent still
out in all the social media.
So let's launch it.
Let's get it going.
So #HumanEnergy.
We're going to start drawing
all this stuff together.
Everything gPause is about.
We're going to pull
together the ideas
that we are energy systems.
And I'm going to touch on a
couple of important aspects
with us as human
energy systems related
to this topic of being able
to move with mindfulness
and heartfulness and
increase our energy.
Necessarily, we've got
to touch on emotions.
You go, uh, emotions.
I don't want to go there.
And the reality is that
I speak from experience,
not wanting to be there.
Having been an engineer,
and I had a great career
with Hewlett-Packard.
Went into consulting.
You can imagine high tech and
then management consulting.
There's not a lot that deal
with emotions in there.
In fact, if anything,
keep it out of the way.
Don't go there.
The reality is that
along the process,
I've learned the
role of emotions.
I've learned how those
relate to energy systems.
So I'm going to share some
important points with that too.
And then we're going to get into
what science research has shown
as really what we believe is
the most valuable tool for being
able to manage
your energy system,
intelligently
manage your energy.
Direct it and be
able to build more.
So we're going to touch
on heart rate variability.
That is the key metric, the
key biofeedback determinant.
And we're going to demonstrate
heart rate variability used
to be able to raise energy
and deliver coherence
and resilience.
Now, those may not be different
words than you've heard.
They won't.
But how they're
used and how they're
going to be used as
we all go forward
in managing our human energy
is very, very important.
So I'm going to
help define those,
and then we're going to put
those into practice as well.
So human energy.
Let's start with the
idea that, first of all,
we are energy systems.
Now, there certainly
is human power,
which is our kinetic abilities.
We can move things.
We move.
There is our metabolism and the
energy in our system, the power
that we have in
our system itself.
We actually produce electricity.
And there's actually
interesting science
going on right now a la
"Matrix" that maybe we
could be our own battery.
A little scary
where that might go,
having "Matrix" as the movie
still prevalent in everybody's
minds.
But we do produce electricity.
Maybe only four watts, but
maybe there's way to harness
more of that.
And the reality in what we think
of as the energy and the power
that we typically understand
that we have, it's depleted,
it's used, it's inefficient.
We have more heat in
the production of energy
that is heat loss.
And so loss of energy.
Most of the time, when we talk
to people about human energy,
it's about the loss and the
inefficiency of our system
and losing energy.
And the reality is
that we're going
to turn that upside
down here, because what
we have to recognize is
that as humans, we expend
and renew energy all day long.
And in that process,
two important aspects
that you may not know about
that science discovered.
One is that we have the
ability to produce energy
from our heart.
And we have a heart field,
an electromagnetic field
of our heart.
This is a computer
generated model
representing the heart
field that has been
measured with magnetometers.
That heart field extends
three feet out from your body.
So what I want you to do it
just reach your arms out.
Go ahead.
Intrude on your neighbors.
Now, that's a little bit less
than your heart field that's
generating right now.
How is that as everybody
arms were over each other?
Well, the reality is
all of your heart fields
are intermingling as well.
And we're going to come
back to that point.
Your heart, as an electrical
device, as your heart beats,
it is creating an
electromagnetic field.
And that is this
three foot field.
And there are other devices
that measure it much, much wider
as well.
But let's stick with
that where the science is
behind this magnetic field,
this electromagnetic field
that we have of the heart.
And the idea that
your heart continues
to beat in producing that field.
And we're not talking about
auras, or more esoteric
or eastern belief in this.
We're talking about real,
measurable electromagnetic
field that you have, we all
have, as long as we're alive.
The other thing is to think
about this energy that's
being produced in this
electromagnetic field
that you have, it's
a carrier wave.
It is a carrier of what
you are experiencing
through your heart.
And what I'm telling you is
that your intentions, thoughts,
and your emotions are
carried as messages
in your electromagnetic field.
What do I mean by that?
Have you walked into a room and
felt kind of dread, or like,
uh, this is icky, or
not this meeting again.
Well, that could
be other reasons.
But have you had that
experience where you just
don't want to be in that spot?
Well, what's happening
is you as a sensor
in this electromagnetic field,
you are receiving information.
But you're also transmitting
information as well.
If you have been
in a place where
it was feeling down like
that, and somebody walks in
and they shift the energy in the
room, or you walk into a room
and the energy feels very
different and you're lifted,
what's happened there?
It is this whole interchange
of this electromagnetic field,
the heart fields,
that is at play here.
It's a real and tangible
sense that you have.
It's a tool you have as well.
It's part of your human energy.
And science calls that, by the
way, a coherent field effect
that is real and measurable.
The more that we
all synchronize--
and we're going
to do some work--
the more we all synchronize
and our heart fields
become coherent, that
coherent field effect creates
that environment that is
a positive and uplifting
environment.
A lot of mindfulness
practice in the meditation
or the breathing, the work
of mindfulness itself,
is even feeding-- it is feeding
this coherent field effect.
So we're going to
build on that as well.
So electromagnetic field
three feet from you.
The other thing with the
human energy to touch on
is that, I mentioned,
you're a battery.
You really are.
We're all batteries.
What do batteries do?
They charge and discharge.
In the case of the battery,
what we're talking about here
is renewing and
depleting all day long.
So what are some of the things
that we are renewing with?
Well, the biggest one
we're supposed to renew
and regenerate is with sleep.
Our sleep cycle is the
biggest regenerator
that we have of
our human energy.
If we're not getting sleep,
and we sustain sleeplessness,
you never get ahead
of-- have enough energy.
And you get towards
the end of the day
and you just don't have
enough left, right?
So another generator,
though, is the practices
that we can do that,
through our heart
and through our
psychophysiology,
are able to produce
and lift energy,
to draw more energy in as a
part of our human energy system.
And so that kind of work is
facilitated through the devices
that we're going to
demonstrate today.
The practices that
we can do that
allow us to harness breath as
the number one tool for being
able to produce our energy.
So as a battery, think
about these two questions.
Each day, right now, you
can think about how are you
charging your battery?
Are you getting enough sleep?
Well, maybe not.
Are you having broken sleep?
If you start with sleep
and sleeplessness,
sleepless disorders are a
big reason for our discharge
and our inability to bring
up that battery-- bring up
our human energy
and our potential.
Are you doing things that
allow you to take a break?
Are you getting into nature?
Are you finding the
ways that you are
able to charge your battery?
There's something
that we're going
to talk about here about
appreciation and compassion
and care.
Accessing that turns out to be
a big lift of energy as well.
What about depleting
or draining?
What's going on that depletes
or drains your battery?
If you allow the first two
or three thoughts to come in,
I would pretty much guess
that something emotional
is in that list.
Something has happened that
is draining your battery.
But it can come from
any of four domains.
It can come from
the physical domain.
Maybe you just really
exhausted your body.
You did a major workout
but didn't allow yourself
the time to rebuild.
Maybe you've got
accumulated things
that are going in your
physiology that don't allow you
to efficiently, in
your systems, be
able to generate more energy.
The emotional domain
over there turns out
to be the most
important in terms
of being able to build
energy, or stop the discharge
or release of energy.
Mentally, this is something
we all in high tech
have got a real challenge.
We are continually processing.
I tell people all the
time, I have an A, B, C,
and a D processor, and the C
and D never stop, for sure.
I try to hold the A processor
in the front, which is
problem solving all the time.
But the reality is,
all four are working
in that hyper-mental state.
I could be exhausting
my energy in that place.
And then even in
terms of spiritually.
Are we operating within some
place that is in our values?
I go to a lot of
places where we're
going to work on the
culture of the company.
And the people's values and
the values of the company
don't match.
And in this domain
over here, people
feel exhausted just
walking in the door.
So you can look at all
four of these domains
for how you're charging and how
you are depleting your energy.
Which brings us
over to emotions.
Now, here's something.
Heart-mind connection.
Let's explore that
just a little bit.
Emotions are key to energy.
I've said that before.
There's something
that happens that when
you experience an emotion,
either deceiving or renewing.
Depleting emotion might be
anger, frustration, anxiety.
When you experience one of those
negative emotions or depleting
emotions, it launches a 1,400
biochemical, hormonal set
of changes in your body that
have as much as a 12-hour tail
to them.
Now, think about that.
That cascade of biochemical
and hormonal reactions is real.
It's measurable.
And it has an effect
on both your psyche
and your physiology both.
It sustains for a long
period of time as well.
In the renewing side,
so happiness aspects,
joy, appreciation,
they also, by the way,
have an equivalent
1,400 biochemical
and hormonal cascade
effect in your body that
also can have a 12-hour tail.
What's going on
the depleting side
is the release of, in
particular, cortisol and all
the effects that cortisol,
that kind of drug in our system
that just takes us down and
hard to get out of a cycle.
Or on the renewing side
is the release of DHEA.
And DHEA is that
joy kind of hormone.
It's the one that
we want to feel.
It's bliss.
The reality is
that our bodies are
trying, as human energy systems,
trying to balance those.
And it's through our
autonomic nervous system
that that balancing
effect is going
on continuously all day long
through the sympathetic,
hitting the gas, and
the parasympathetic,
hitting the brake,
part of our system.
We're wired to have this
continual back and forth
to be able to balance our
system and balance our bodies.
Our heart sits right in the
middle of that whole process.
Our heart is where emotions
are being encoded and affecting
our energy and what
we do all day long.
That autonomic nervous
system regulates about 90%
of your energy and the
functions that related to that,
so it's breathing,
heart beat, digestion,
immune, hormonal responses.
They're all affected in our
autonomic nervous system.
So the emotions part
gets very interesting,
because with our
emotions, did you
know you have 40,000
neurons in your heart?
How many people knew that?
OK, a few.
And just to be complete, by
the way, you have 86 billion
in your brain, and you have
about 100 million in your gut.
And those are all
interconnected.
Now, the 40,000 neurons in
your heart, very interesting.
These have been known
about for a long time,
but only it was about 20 years
ago began to be explored more.
And the organization that
VeraHeart is aligned with,
the Institute of HeartMath,
is the leading researchers
and practitioners.
A lot of what we're covering
here and the devices
that we're going to use are
from Institute of HeartMath,
where they've explored
what's going on
with the heart-mind connection.
What's going on
with these neurons.
For instance, here's a little
known fact, but very important.
There's a cluster of these
neurons in your heart
that when you hold a feeling
of appreciation, care,
or compassion for
just about 10 seconds,
you hold that, you feel
it in your heart, that
sends a message to the
frontal cortex of your brain.
And it launches a very specific
hormonal and biochemical set
of changes in your body
that carry joy and carry
appreciation, carry it
throughout your system.
You're in control of
that through being
able to hold that
kind of attention
with appreciation,
care, or compassion.
Again, research
proven, peer reviewed,
published research that
is out there that's
talking about this heart-mind
connection with emotions.
Our emotions are really
centered through communication
with the heart to the brain,
and through the channel
of the brain, the
medulla and the amygdala.
And then up into the cortex.
The reality is when you
measure the communications that
are happening through the vagus
nerve, through this connection
here, the heart is
communicating way more
with the brain than the
brain with the heart.
Let me say that again.
The heart is continually
communicating
more with the brain than
the brain with the heart.
A significant disparity in that.
The heart is trying to
send messages all the time.
The heart is sending
those same messages
in an electromagnetic field.
And by being able to
do spectral analysis
of our electromagnetic-- your
heart field, science now,
researchers can predict
with 75% accuracy what
emotions you're experiencing.
That's pretty phenomenal
to be 75% accurate
using spectral analysis of
your electromagnetic field
on emotions.
Your emotions are
centered around
this heart-mind connection.
And that's what's taken
VeraHeart, my company, and us
into focusing more
on, so what really
is going on with the heart
in these communications that
are continually happening?
What the heart is signaling.
There's other research
that really astounded me.
What researchers love to
do is to hook up people
to computers, of course, right?
Brain activity,
heart monitoring,
skin conductance, so on.
And in this particular
study, there
was a very significant
breakthrough done
with Institute of HeartMath.
They would serve up
either a horrific image
or a beautiful, joyful
image, randomly selected
by the computer.
And the participants that
went through that study,
they had control.
They had the clicker to decide
when the image would come up.
Peer reviewed study itself.
And here's what the
astounding thing for me.
Before the computer randomly
selected whichever image,
the heart knew with
a greater accuracy
whether it was the
horrific or the beautiful,
and sent a message to the brain.
That's before the image was
selected by the computer.
And then the image
comes, sensory,
we get the visual sense.
The brain then gets the
message and then sends
a whole lot of messages
out through the body.
What is going on there?
That is a huge, huge
piece of science
that is just now
being dug into deeper.
Our heart knows something more.
Our heart is sensing
things in this field.
Our heart is connected
to our brain,
trying to help our brain
be prepared for what
we are going to experience.
Be prepared for
lifting our energy.
Remember, the heart is connected
to our autonomic nervous
system, obviously.
And it is sending signals
through the system,
causing this release of
chemical and hormonal changes
in our body.
Your heart is way
more active in what
is going on with your
energy than you're aware.
And this now is--
the good news is
that we have the ability to
manage that, intelligently
manage.
And that's where we get
into heart rate variability.
So heart rate variability
gives us a measurable window.
It gives us the tool.
And what it is simply
is when we look
at the amount of time
between heartbeats,
and then we compare those,
that's heart rate variability.
It's a simple measure.
Now, I love simple models
and simple measures.
Maybe it's because I can't
figure out the complex ones.
Or maybe I'm just too
tired of complexity.
But this is simple.
It also is very quickly
becoming much, much more
a reliable predictor of
many, many different things
in health care and the
health care research fields.
That's fundamentally what heart
rate variability is all about.
As the heart is sending messages
to the brain, what's happening
is that the variance between
heartbeats is shifting.
That's a part of emotions,
thoughts coming back.
This is continual interchange
and adjustment in our systems
to try to find balance.
Or if the heart's
sensing something
to get ready to react
to, then what happens?
Heart beats faster, right?
Variability.
Shifts to be able to-- and
reflecting this increase--
a decrease in the amount
of time in between,
but the increased heart rate.
And just the opposite
occurs as well.
So emotions are
changing our physiology.
We talked about that.
Well, depleting emotions create
an incoherent heart rhythm.
A greater degree of
shifts in the variability
of heart rhythm.
And renewing emotions,
those that lift our energy,
create a more harmonious
or coherent pattern
in the shifts of our
heart rate variability.
And the physiology
too, by the way.
As you breathe in, that
increases your heartbeat.
And as you exhale,
you get a decrease.
That's one effect of
increase and decrease,
but not the total effect.
So what we have is a tool to
be able to look at heart rate
variability.
Now what I want to do is
demonstrate heart rate
variability in action.
So I need a volunteer.
Someone who wants to come up
and experience the biofeedback
device that we have.
OK.
Come on up.
You raised your hat.
It's like an auction.
You know.
You had an auction paddle
that you lifted up.
Thanks for coming up.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LANE MICHEL: Oh,
did I miss someone?
OK, we'll make time.
Yeah, right there is good.
All right.
We're just going to hook that
right up to your earlobe there.
Now, what we're actually
using is a biofeedback tool
and a piece of software
from Institute of HeartMath.
It's called emWave.
This is the emWave Pro version.
So that you can
all see it and we
can demonstrate what's
going on with it,
the sensor is an optical sensor.
It's actually detecting pulse.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Chris.
LANE MICHEL: Chris.
It's detecting Chris's pulse.
And you see-- Chris
won't see, because Chris
can't turn around.
But it's showing us that
there's a good read,
so we've got good data.
This is reliable data
to be able to look
at how this device can provide
feedback or measure heart
rate variability.
So as this device
is working, one
assumes it's just literally
trying to help encode.
It helps encode
this variability.
So those beat to beat
changes that are happening.
And as Chris is
experiencing standing here
with all of you staring at
Chris, who obviously loves
this, it's like his
body is reacting,
his heart is reacting.
Are you reacting, do you think?
AUDIENCE: A little bit.
LANE MICHEL: You don't
look like you're reacting.
On the surface, you look
kind of calm there, Chris.
So let me tell you
about these devices.
First of all, this
is the emWave Pro.
There's actually a
device which is emWave2.
This is a standalone device
that does the exact same kind
of measures.
You get software
very close to this
that you load onto your
system, Mac or Windows.
And you can take this anywhere.
And what it does is help--
it's an entrainment device,
a biofeedback device
that helps you
to find a natural way of being
able to have the kind of heart
rate variability that's going to
build coherence and resilience.
And I'm going to start using
those terms as we go forward.
So with these tools-- oh,
I'm sorry. [INAUDIBLE].
There's also another device.
There's an app.
The current app as iOS.
Why do they always start
with iOS instead of Droid?
I mean, come on.
Let's create a shift here.
The Droid version comes out at
the end of the year, I'm told.
Fundamentally, this app,
this is the iOS version,
has the ability to
do the same thing
as that standalone device,
entrainment, biofeedback,
being able to use
heart rate variability.
OK.
So we're all going
to get a chance
to use the most fundamental
part of improving
heart rate variability.
And this is called
heart focused breathing.
And so I invite you all to do
this with Chris and myself.
So in your seat, find just
a comfortable position
in your seat.
Are you comfortable, Chris?
AUDIENCE: Mm-hmm.
LANE MICHEL: OK.
You've looked comfortable
all along, but not really.
Right?
I have data proving otherwise.
OK.
So in that comfortable place,
pay attention to your heart
now.
If you want to, you can put
your hand over your heart.
Begin breathing through your
heart, through your chest area.
Breathe a little deeper
and slower than normal.
Five seconds in and
five seconds out.
Again, five seconds in
and five seconds out.
Five seconds in and
five seconds out.
Continue that breathing.
And as you're breathing a little
slower and deeper than usual,
just allow your mind to give
you a feeling of appreciation,
care, compassion for
someone or something.
Whatever comes in.
Allow it to come in and
just hold that in your heart
as you're breathing.
Continue the five seconds
in and five seconds out.
We'll do one more cycle of five
seconds in and five seconds
out.
OK.
So I'll stop the data recording.
Chris, thank you.
We're going to let you go.
[APPLAUSE]
This way you get to
see your data too.
OK.
Well, first of all, Chris,
you're going to live.
That's the good news.
All kidding aside, turns out
that heart rate variability
is one of the emerging
best predictors
of all cause mortality.
That is a very
fancy way of saying
if you want to know if you're
building longevity or not,
this is a good
indicator of that.
In fact, heart
rate variability is
now, through the
research being done,
is able to predict someone's
age within about four years.
And that is because that what
happens is when we're younger,
we have greater variability,
greater amplitude in this wave.
And that reduces over the years.
And so given no other
changes, science
can predict your age
within about four years.
But the good news is
you can fool science
by working with
these kinds of tools.
So here's what happened.
We hooked up Chris.
Chris is actually-- Chris,
are you in the gPause group?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
LANE MICHEL: OK.
So you might have been
using some of that,
or you might just have
all the benefits of gPause
already going that's not too
bad of a range of rhythm that's
going.
Right here is where we started
the heart focused breathing.
And what do you notice
about the change in there?
I look at it and say,
well, first of all, there's
a more even kind of
wave that's going on.
There's greater amplitude.
And it's clustered
together as well.
And you have about a 15
point spread over here.
What you want to have
is something that
looks kind of like a sine wave.
That's showing a level of
coherence in heart rate
variability.
And then the more
amplitude, that's
indicating more resilience.
That's indicating more
youth, is one way people
like it described.
OK, good.
How are we doing time-wise?
I think we're doing OK
to bring up one more.
Did you want to come up?
Now that you've seen it?
Come on, why not?
We've got time.
AUDIENCE: What does
the red indicate?
LANE MICHEL: That
is a drop of data.
And then the pickup of data
indicates that it's still
a valuable set of data.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Tiffany.
LANE MICHEL: Tiffany.
Welcome Tiffany.
I should have asked.
OK to hook you up?
AUDIENCE: Is this live?
LANE MICHEL: It is now.
OK.
So what we're
going to do is just
get Tiffany started out now.
Tiffany has a little advantage
in that Chris kind of was
the real Guinea
pig and didn't have
the benefit of all the other
pieces that we went through.
So you have a little
bit more responsibility
to generate a sine wave.
No pressure, Tiffany, at all.
Have you been up in
front of groups before?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
LANE MICHEL: See, this is like
interesting how-- so you're
kind of in an even place?
You don't feel
stressed or anything?
AUDIENCE: Not particularly.
More and more.
LANE MICHEL: More and more?
The more I talk?
OK.
So what we're going
to do is as a group,
we're going to do the heart
focused breathing again.
And we'll step into that.
Go ahead and pay attention
to the area of your heart.
You can put your
hand over your heart
if you want to, feeling
your chest rise and fall.
Begin breathing through your
heart or your chest area,
just a little slower
and deeper than usual.
Five seconds in and five seconds
out is a very good pattern.
Five seconds out, breathing out.
And five seconds in.
Five seconds out.
Now, as you're continuing this
five seconds in and out rhythm,
allow your mind to give you a
feeling of appreciation, care,
and compassion for
someone or something.
Hold that in your heart.
Continue breathing.
We'll do one more cycle, five
seconds in, five seconds out.
Great.
Now come back to center
in your chair, eyes open.
Oh, let me shut
you off here first.
Wouldn't want you
to get a shock.
No, there's no shock.
Thank you, Tiffany.
[APPLAUSE]
So we can look at
Tiffany's data.
I could adjust the
scale, but don't need to.
We started out, and
she was pre-practiced.
Already knew what was coming.
But this was kind
of just sitting
in the chair for
just about a minute.
And then we started the
heart focused breathing.
And you very quickly went
right into a sinus rhythm.
Just a very nice
sine wave and flow.
You have an amplitude.
This-- we could pull
up the data but it
won't be much below here--
of somewhere around 10
to 15 points.
So Chris had you a little
bit beat there in resilience.
Not that there has
to be a competition,
but you have a new goal.
OK, well, thank you for both
for being our Guinea pigs
and demonstrating the tool.
This data that
comes from the tool
is the same data that used in
the devices that I showed you.
And it allows you to be able
to train yourself and get
the benefits of what's happening
with heart rate variability.
So in recap, this is actually
the same kind of process.
Somebody sitting up in a chair.
And at the point the data
ends here, come around here,
they begin heart
focused breathing
and that additional
part that I added
in which is called
a heart lock-in,
in Institute of HeartMath terms.
What's happening
in this top scale,
was for Chris and a
little bit for Tiffany,
is a more erratic, more
incoherent type of pattern
in the biofeedback tool.
And that's indicating that--
that jerky pattern is generated
indicating that their autonomic
nervous system is doing
a lot of adjustments, between
the release of cortisol
or DHEA, the messages
with emotions experienced.
Maybe sitting in
front of an audience.
It might be a phone
call that you're on,
or a phone call that
you have to make.
Anything that
could-- or an in-law.
Something would
cause you to have
this kind of erratic pattern.
Why is Danielle laughing?
[LAUGHTER]
We'll talk later.
So this erratic pattern
here impairs performance.
In fact, it greatly
impairs performance.
It is a huge indicator
of confusion,
of depleting energy, in
particular that we talked about
before, it's an indicator
of even impaired judgment.
Communication won't be as clear.
A whole lot of factors
have been tested, measured,
and they indicate a lot of
times why teens have problems
in working together too.
As opposed to establishing
this kind of more sine wave
pattern, where we can
reach optimal performance.
And the thing that VeraHeart,
we're doing right now is we're
teaming up with some-- our
coaches and consultants teaming
up with others to begin
working with companies, teams
and companies, to shift
them out of there into this.
And measure the
difference in achievement
in terms of what
their goals are.
And also happiness
at work, being
able to be more
fulfilled at work,
express their values, and so on.
A lot of different factors.
So that's what we're
doing with heart rate
variability with our people.
This is the devices that
I held up and shared.
They're available through
VeraHeart or directly
from Institute of HeartMath.
$129 to $199 are the prices.
They're very affordable devices.
These devices have
been out-- the emWave
has been over 10 years.
And it's gone through
a generation of change.
The iOS version of this Inner
Balance and the Droid versions
coming out are newer.
But they fundamentally
are using the same proven,
tested algorithms,
same kind of tools
to be able to continue to build
more coherence and resilience.
So let's talk about
those now, because I've
been hinting around to
them for a little bit.
Coherence.
Full disclosure-- that's
my sine wave up there.
That's my run from
about a week ago.
I'm trying to get
more resilience,
but coherence, that's
looking pretty good.
Now, also in full disclosure,
six months ago when
I began work, it didn't
look like that at all.
It looked like that
frustration kind of curve.
Very mental kind of,
very even emotional.
I have to admit, emotional type
of effects that were there.
But now I'm able to jump into
that kind of coherent place.
So what is coherence?
It is defined as that optimal
state in which heart, mind,
and emotions are
aligned and in sync.
In effect, through the
autonomic nervous system,
through the messages from
the heart to the brain,
and then the effects
that come from that.
There's greater synchronization.
And the heart and emotions, much
more involved in that process.
Our immune, hormonal,
nervous systems
function in this
energetic coordination.
That's the definition
of coherence.
What it means is that we are
more efficiently and more
intelligently managing
our human energy.
So this is the magic
coherence is our ability
to manage human energy.
And it's represented
in that sine wave look,
as opposed to the jagged,
incoherent type of rhythm.
OK?
Then there's resilience.
Resilience-- now with this
knowledge of heart rate
variability, the tools
that you can use as well,
resilience is the ability
to build your capacity
for human energy, holding,
regenerating, and then using
your human energy.
Say that again,
Resilience is the ability
to build your capacity
for human energy.
So it's to prepare
for, recover from,
and adapt in the face of
stress, challenge, adversity.
The resilience is that
measure that-- when
you're about to
go into something
that's going to be stressful,
don't just walk right in.
You take just a pause.
Just a few seconds, even,
can make a big difference.
But a few minutes can make
a whole world of difference.
You can visualize going
into a resilient pattern,
moving from this erratic
anticipation of what's
going to happen,
anticipation in the emotions
means you're releasing
a flood of chemicals
that are depleting
you before you even
go into your situation.
You activate the
heart-mind connection,
become more resilient,
more coherent as well,
and you're going to be
better prepared for whatever
you're going into.
So heart rate variability then,
it is providing all these--
I'll let you read
those benefits.
But fundamentally, these come
out of published, peer reviewed
research.
Now, if you go to Google
Scholar and look at HeartMath
is the lead research
group for 20 years
in heart-mind connection.
The number of citations from
other groups and them is huge.
There are 263 published
pieces of works
from Institute of HeartMath
that are heavily cited.
These are results out of a
lot of these published works.
The science that's
been conducted behind
and the practices
that have come out
of the Institute of HeartMath.
And the work we do to
extend those practices to be
able to share with
you and with others.
There's a paper-- Rollin
McCraty is the head of research
for Institute of HeartMath.
He has a fantastic paper
that summarizes this,
and that I've talked about,
but a whole lot more.
And it's consistent heart-based,
positive emotion techniques
that they're looking at,
show greater self-management,
your ability to manage
your energy system,
and better regulation of
your physiology, even.
So in my book,
that means that we
become more resilient, more
healthy, more able to harness
and access our energy in
a shorter amount of time.
So that paper is called
"Heart-Brain Neurodynamics."
It was published in 2015.
So recently done,
published piece.
And if you go to Google
Scholar under HeartMath,
you'll find that
published there.
What it really comes down
to, heart rate variability,
if you just take five to 10
minutes, five times a week,
practicing that same breathing
that I just shared with you,
you will have the effect
of moving into more
coherence and more resilience.
It's even that little bit
makes a huge, huge shift.
Now extend it.
If you start your
day-- so what I did
was as I began working
with these tools,
and I've been heavily working
with them for about a year,
and then six months ago, I
shifted my whole morning.
Now, my morning was this.
I got up.
What'd I do?
My phone, and began
looking at the news,
my email, social media.
Got a company to run.
I need to know what the pulse
is in the morning, right?
So at 6:00 AM, I'm
already feeding myself
with admittedly a whole
stream of negative news,
a whole bunch of challenges
that come in on e-mail.
And some good things too.
But now I'm being
rocked both ways.
And I realized that that
wasn't very mindful.
And it certainly
wasn't heartful.
I shifted my entire routine.
Now the first half hour starts--
OK, big admission here-- yoga.
Yoga is my way of life now.
I mean, I really have
found the benefits of yoga.
That yoga that starts
out for five minutes,
I go into my own mantra,
my own meditation work.
I use this same tool here
with the HeartMath tool.
And within 30 minutes,
I've either established
or reestablished that coherent
rhythm and greater resilience.
When I've reached that level,
I'm ready to get my day going.
I'm a completely
different person.
And that six months
of work, I mean,
it was a month of
establishing new habits,
and then maintaining
that for another month.
And it is just my habit.
You could do that.
It has a huge effect
and a huge impact.
But you can start.
So the HeartMath part of this?
10 minutes of my morning.
And I do that seven days a week.
That's how I got that curve,
by the way, that data run.
OK.
So where mindfulness
meets heartful.
I've mentioned a
couple times pause.
With VeraHeart, one of the
things we're- we've threatened
to start a movement
of pause for choice.
And I think we're
going to do it.
We got the domain name.
You heard it here right
now-- pauseforchoice.com.
We'll get it live
within a week or two.
The whole idea is this.
I'm convinced if this
world inserted a pause
before speaking or
acting in any way,
and that pause can be a few
seconds to a few minutes,
we'd have a completely
different world.
It allows us to
have the heart send
a message to the
brain to wake up,
become more aware
of mindfulness,
and pull ourselves
in our center.
And full awareness, full
attention, and intention.
And then we go about whatever
we have to deal with.
That golden pause
shifts everything.
We teach that to
everybody we work with.
First thing and foremost, pause.
And the pause begins with
even just one breath.
It allows you to access so
much more wisdom, so much more
of your energy,
your human energy.
#HumanEnergy.
Seriously, folks,
within two weeks
I want that hashtag
like climbing way up,
because it's nowhere right now.
I had our team launch like a
bunch of hashtag human energies
today because I
wanted to use it here.
And it's nowhere.
So if it goes
somewhere, thank you.
You all did it.
And it will.
So pause, number one.
Appreciate.
So when I mentioned
let your mind
serve up a feeling of
appreciation, care,
or compassion, that is accessing
this appreciation second step.
Now, here's the key.
If you can radiate
that-- and so I used
radiate-- three feet,
electromagnetic field, right?
You've got that appreciation,
care, compassion, radiate it.
Send it in your field.
Let it go more than three
feet, what the heck?
Have a joyful time with it.
That is mindfulness
meeting heartfulness.
Third, listen.
You have so much intuition,
intelligence, and wisdom
that you have access to.
And those who are in
mindfulness practices know that.
They access more.
Now, bring the heart and
more with some of these tools
as well.
And you go deeper.
And your senses begin to expand.
We live a lot of
life de-sensitized.
There's so much coming
at us all the time.
Let's reopen our senses,
and do that in a way that
allows us to be heartful.
Fourth is to connect.
And a good way to think in
this electromagnetic field
is HeartMath has a great way.
They say, what are you
putting in the field today?
So are you generating
positive thoughts?
Are you generating
things that help others?
Are you putting
love in the field?
Are you experiencing
thoughts of love
or are you expressing love?
Is that coming
out in your field?
Care, compassion, things
that uplift people.
You have the responsibility
for your electromagnetic field.
What are you going to put in it?
What are you transmitting?
And fourth is solutions.
We are-- listen,
it's about results.
It's about achievement.
We are in a world that respects
achievement and results,
and it should.
We're not doing this
just for joy and kicks.
We're doing this
because we've got
a world that's going so
fast and accelerating more.
Moore's law is
not going to stop.
I don't care how many
people predict it
over how many decades,
it doesn't stop.
It won't stop.
It's going to keep going.
We're going to have things
continue to accelerate,
not just with technology
and information,
but in the area of this new
space, our senses, our ability
to sense more, our ability
to be more in touch
with others through our field.
And so solutions can
come in personal health,
but also in smarter decisions
and more results that
get more done.
So heart focused breathing.
Remember that when
we do training,
that is the base tool.
The one that I shared with you.
You can continue using
that, and expand on it
with the appreciation.
But that is the most fundamental
tool and it creates the pause.
So recapping, I
kind of like this.
Scientific research has
finally collided with,
you can call it
spiritual practices.
Gregg Braden actually
created that kind of idea
that we've brought
these two together.
And he's right.
Our brain was believed
to be the master organ.
And it's not the master organ.
It's part of a system, a
distributed system that masters
who we are.
Our heart drives
our #HumanEnergy.
And that recognition
of the role of emotions
is the key determinant of your
energy depleting or renewing.
Once you have that
in consciousness,
you're already going to start
increasing your human energy,
increasing your personal energy.
The heart field is present.
It's real.
It's measurable.
You're transmitting and
receiving all day long.
And our human energy
capacity can grow.
We can be more resilient.
We can be more coherent.
We are in control of being
able to increase that.
Published research
that's out there,
I encourage you to go
look into HearthMath.org.
Go to Google Scholar, look
at the citations here.
This peer reviewed
work is fundamentally
starting to take hold and
launch and move forward.
So thank you very much.
I think we have a few
minutes for questions.
OK.
[APPLAUSE]
VAN RIPER: Questions.
LANE MICHEL: You can
make up a question.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious
about this heart field.
I know that electric
fields don't
stop at a particular place.
You talked three feet.
What is the heart field.
Is it electromagnetic field
coming out of the-- is it
electromagnetic
field of neurons?
I'm sorry, what do you see in
it when you actually measure it?
I understand what
you're measuring
with the pulse on the ear,
but I don't understand what
you mean by the heart field.
LANE MICHEL: It's a
magnetometer in this case.
In hospitals, I believe
SQUIDs are used.
But what's happening is your
heart, the way it pumps,
is through electrical signals.
To pump and have that
rhythm that it's got.
Anything that's an
electrical on and off
creates a magnetic field.
And so what you
really are generating
is the signals for
your heart are creating
that magnetic field itself.
Think of it, it's
not really on-off,
but that's the way I
communicate it sometimes.
That boom-boom,
boom-boom, boom-boom.
That creates a measurable
electronic field.
Now, the other thing
that's interesting
is your brain has
electrical activity too.
Anybody have any idea how
big the electromagnetic field
of the brain is?
One to two inches.
That's an astounding
difference in power,
energy that's going on.
So that is a real measurable
electromagnetic field
from that pulse that
creates your heartbeat.
OK?
Did that answer your
question all the way?
AUDIENCE: Well, I understand how
there is electromagnetic field
created whenever you have
an alternating current
in something.
And in a previous job,
I worked with people
who were using SQUID technology,
superconducting something
or others, to measure
brain magneto dynamics,
or something of the brain.
What I don't quite
understand is--
or another thing I'm a
little uncertain about
is how you say that different
people's heart fields interact.
What is the receiving
part of that?
I understand how it's generated.
What do you mean by receiving?
LANE MICHEL: Yeah.
Well, the receiving side-- the
only way I can answer that.
I'm not a neuroscience
neuro-- actually,
I have neurocardiologists
now who do this work.
They're measuring
the receiving side
of others' emotions or other
fields as they interact.
And so that can create
a coherent field
effect that's measurable.
That there's an increase
in a particular coherence
of heart rhythms.
So here's an example of measure.
I'm Four people,
three of which do
that heart focused breathing.
They've learned the techniques
to get a coherent rhythm.
The fourth person, no
experience, not even told.
They're blind to
what's going on.
All get together.
They're just at
the table together.
All four are hooked up.
Some number of minutes, I
think it was six minutes in.
I don't remember
exactly, but some amount
of time that they run, the three
are cued to start doing heart
focused breathing.
Same thing you did.
They establish coherent field.
With a very, very
short amount of time,
the fourth person goes
into coherence as well.
And they're not
doing any breathing.
They're not doing any of these--
they don't know the techniques.
They're unconscious to it.
They're receiving
from the others.
And that's the best I can answer
in terms of the science that's
going on behind it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
VAN RIPER: We have time for
maybe one more question.
LANE MICHEL: One more question.
VAN RIPER: Or not.
Well, if you're-- oh.
LANE MICHEL: One there.
AUDIENCE: So I've never
believed in people
being able to see
people's auras.
But now that you've
been saying that,
do you think it's possible that
people can see others auras?
LANE MICHEL: Well, that's
a question completely
different from what
I was addressing,
but that answer is yes.
I do believe.
And I think there's other
things that are going on.
There's other intuitive
senses, other tools
that we have that
are-- they're not
part of what I was
covering, but yes, I
do believe that is the case.
And I think that's a whole
area that's opening up more.
Which is just fascinating.
Because when we talk about the
bigger topic of energy, I mean,
listen, we're all just energy.
Matter is just the
placement of, the potential
of energy at any time.
We know that from quantum side.
So yeah, I believe a lot more
is going to be discovered.
AUDIENCE: That's awesome.
Thank you.
LANE MICHEL: Yeah.
We have a lot of
good fun with that.
VAN RIPER: So unfortunately, we
have to wrap up today's talk.
But Lane is staying
here for lunch.
We're going to be
going to big table,
so if anyone has a question they
were too shy to bring up here,
they can bring it
to lunch with us.
So thank you for
coming out, everyone.
And thank you, Lane.
LANE MICHEL: Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]